the mind is not wandering aimlessly so
the surface of the mind is this active
thinking mind gotta gotta got a monkey
mind all that
and every human being is thinks that
sometimes I'd like to have some inner
calm some inner quiet some inner ease
right now there's a level of the Mind
deep within a Transcendent level of the
mind that is already calm quiet peaceful
and yet the source of our creativity
intelligence happiness and
Transcendental Meditation gives
effortless access to that so when you
learn TM from a teacher you learn how to
just allow the attention of your mind to
be drawn Inward and without any effort
as a matter of fact any effort stops the
process without any effort your mind is
just gently settles down and when that
happens your body gains a steep state of
rest cortisol levels are reduced and you
feel rejuvenated